- We're here with Eugene Levy,
give it up!
His new book is called
Best Wishes Warmest Regards,
the story of Schitt's Creek.
It's out right now.
I miss Schitt's Creek.
Do you miss it?
Cause it was such a great cast.
- I actually do.
I do miss it.
I miss doing it.
When we actually wrapped the series,
I said to myself,
what are we doing?
This is so going on.
But, it was the right decision.
- Yeah, ugh.
I mean maybe.
It was such a-
I was so sad.
- Well, you never want
to take a chance
that you're going to
go into another season,
then it's just not going
to be quite as good.
- I get it, I get it,
but at the same time, mad, whatever.
And do you ever watch old episodes,
like when they come on?
- Well, now that the show
is in syndication of,
you know,
when you're kind of channel flipping,
I will sometimes see the show on the air,
and to be honest,
I can watch it now
as if I wasn't really in it.
You know?
I mean I can actually watch it
as a television episode,
just to see how everything holds up,
you know,
because when you're doing a show,
you have a tendency sometimes
to maybe only look at yourself
when you're looking at the show.
I don't know if you ever
kind of go through that at all,
but you find yourself focused
on yourself quite a bit,
just to see how am I doing?
How am I, you know,
how do I look in this scene?
Well that's great.
I mean, this is great.
I'm holding up my end of the scene.
And then the more you kind of,
you know,
see it during the editing process
and everything else,
the more you're looking at an episode,
then you kind of notice
everything else, right?
But it's an actors thing I think.
I don't honestly know if
it's possible for an actor to look
at himself in a scene
and look at the scene
without looking at himself.
I mean, it's-
- I was gonna say that's yeah.
Well, it is amazing though,
to point out though,
editors are amazing
because after doing the voice,
like it's one of those
things where you're in it.
So you, like you said, you're in it,
you're doing your thing,
but then you watch it back
and how they edit it together.
These people are so
gifted at what they do.
They make you look funnier.
They make you like,
they make the show better.
I'm just like, wait,
that's not how it happened.
What? that was like,
Yeah, they make us look way better.
The editors are amazing.
- Yeah, cause there's
too many moments you can remember
as being kind of bad moments
that I wish I could take back,
and yet you don't see it.
- They're good.
- When it's in in the
final product, Right?
Because they've, they have snipped it out.
- Yeah.
- Good.
- I know, God bless them.
So why did you like really?
Why did you want to
write a book on the show?
- You know, our fans are,
when it comes to Schitt's Creek knowledge,
they are the most intelligent,
they're like Mensa.
They they know every single thing
about the show,
so we wanted to give them a book
that they would find interesting,
and things in the book
that they actually would find interesting,
and not necessarily know everything about.
Right?
And on social media over the years,
when we were doing our show,
a lot of great stuff would come out
in social media,
the, you know, people would be painting
you know, things,
and caricatures,
and settings and scenes.
And we used a lot of that fan art
in the, in the book
as an acknowledgement
to the people who actually went above
and beyond in helping
to promote the show that they loved.
And it's the actors talking
about their characters,
and talking about their favorite scenes
in the show and,
oh God,
everything you wanted
to know about Moira's wigs.
And it's, I mean, it's all in there,
and we're hoping
that the fans really, really love it.
- Oh, I imagine there'll be so proud too.
It's so cool of you to involve them.
Like, you know,
to have them be a part of it as well.
That's so cool.
- Well, they were such a big part
of the success of our show
because they, you know,
social media,
when people take to what you do
and they're so passionate about it.
- It can turn things around.
- It can really turn things around.
They can't stop talking about it
and it became infectious.
It really helps spread the word.
So this was like a little love letter
to our fans.
- Well, speaking of
wigs, you brought it up.
The book has this picture of you,
which is fantastic.
So what's going on here
and how many drugs were you on?
- Well, that was a take-
(Eugene laughing)
that was taken on our,
after we wrapped the series,
after our very last scene,
doing the show,
which was outside of the Rosebud motel.
And we finished,
we popped some champagne
and I was feeling rather Merry.
And one of Moira's wigs
was being kind of passed around one
of the trailers at that point.
And we were all kind of,
you know,
in there together telling stories,
and congratulating each other,
and crying and saying goodbye.
And somebody put the wig on me,
and I, it felt so good.
(Laughter)
- I do feel like you should have
an English accent
and you should be stoned.
I think it would be a
really great character
for something.
Well, Dan, read some things
on the show just to tease you, right?
What was one?
I heard it had to do something
maybe with your hair.
- Yeah, well, yeah, there was one,
(Laughter)
- I love this episode
- that's the one.
Okay, I'm a little picky
about my hair and it's not,
you know, it's not vanity it's not vanity.
It's just really tough hair
to do, you know, for me.
I mean, I'm looking at
it now and it's like,
it's got a little whoopity doo curl
in the front.
I can't do anything about it.
So I'm kinda touchy about,
you know, just getting my hair,
It takes a while to get my hair
to look the way I think it should.
He wrote an episode called the drip,
where I'm lying in bed
and all night a drip has been dripping
on my head and I wake up soaked.
And I, you know, when I read the scene,
I said,
ah, Dan really?
It can't drip anywhere else,
except on my hair?
I mean, yeah,
okay, okay, I'll do it.
We were shooting the scene,
and I take a break
and I look in that little hand mirror.
I said, can I borrow a little mirror
and I check the mirror
and I'm going, okay.
It's all right.
I think I can live with this.
And then I hear a voice saying,
I think it should be more wet.
That was Daniel
It was Daniel.
And I said, really?
He said, yeah,
I don't think it's going to play
Unless it, it's really
got to look like it's wet.
- This is for not getting
him something at Christmas.
- Yeah this is, it's from something.
And I could never
to this day track exactly what it was,
but we did the scene
and he got such a kick out of it.
Honestly, I mean,
I got as much fun watching him,
watching me being as miserable
as I was doing the scene,
but it all worked for the scene,
and I got it,
and I knew why the hair had to be wet.
So I went ahead and did it.
- You leaned in.
- I leaned in.
- That's a real man y'all.
- Well I'm a pro.